aquí tenemos el número 46 tenemos cuatro
en la posición de las decenas que
literalmente representa cuatro decenas y
las podemos ver aquí una dos tres cuatro
decenas Esta es una
decena Esta es otra
decena Esta es otra decena y esta es
otra decena cada una de estas es una
decena de cuadros y juntas representan
cuatro decenas o 40 cuadros morados y
luego tenemos un seis en el lugar de las
unidades y lo podemos ver aquí 1 2 3 4 5
6 Así que podemos decir que 46 es igual
a cuatro decenas más 6 unidades ahora
vamos a hacer algo interesante vamos a
restar cuatro unidades de este 46 vamos
a pensar Qué significa restar cuatro
unidades de
46 Entonces tenemos
46 y le vamos a restar cu Cuál va a ser
el resultado de esto Cuántas decenas
vamos a tener aquí más un cierto número
de unidades y aquí voy a poner las
unidades estoy dejando Estos espacios en
blanco aquí entonces Cuántas decenas
vamos a tener Bueno a este 46 le vamos a
restar 4ro unidades le quitamos cuatro
unidades una dos 3 cu Y cuántas decenas
nos quedan seguimos teniendo cuatro
decenas vamos a escribir eso aquí cuatro
decenas y ahora Cuántas unidades tenemos
Ahora solo tenemos dos unidades podemos
ver que si tenemos 46 cuatro decenas y
seis unidades y le restamos cuatro
unidades 6 unidades menos 4 unidades es
igual a dos unidades lo volvemos a
escribir
46 men cu es igual a cuatro decenas nos
queda este cuatro en la posición de las
decenas y dos en la posición de las
unidades y podemos ver aquí que en la
posición de las unidades restamos cuatro
unidades de estas
seis